so this is going to be a fifth start
coming off a game where he gave up eight
runs a little sketchy as far as the
eight runs
conor harvey gave up two inherited
runners and then uh they played horrible
defense
did go one solo home run to jose ramirez
who hits home runs over off everybody
fastball
pretty much you know he's got all the
pitches and
so the new rules you can't use anything
to spin the ball a little bit more
and aitkin's first pitch grounded to
short galves up with it one pitch one
out
[Applause]
paul's going to feel a little different
2-2 and he gets him
strike on the inside corner mccormick
down for the second hour
[Applause]
ball hit sharply that's off the glove of
franco
brantley will get to second and hold
there yuli guriel sharply hit baseball
down the third baseline that will
probably be scored a hit it is
trying to get him out
to be pitch number 20. and it's strike
three call
alvarez frozen at the plate
well mccormick goes down on strikes and
just can't get the bet going
jayco de rizzi on the mound
right-handed for the houston astros came
into relief last time out for lance
mccullers as a piggy back he looked
great four innings didn't walk a batter
struck out three didn't allow an earned
run giving up two hits he'd like to
continue success in a ballpark where he
has been successful at
jose altuve julie guriel on the right
side and jason castro who has caught
four of jayco to rizzi's seven starts as
oda rizzy gets the fastball by cedric
mullins
for a strikeout it's that little rosin
bag behind the mount
you know they instituted that why can't
they do something similar for everybody
across the board but jacob derisi looks
good up in the zone so far
is that a change up up might be the
cutter the cutter he got
this year or in future years and here he
is with 14 home runs 52 rbis
as he grounds one to carlos correa good
start to this one for jake odorizzi a
couple of strikeouts and a ground up
and strike three called
all three strikeouts for keegan aiken
looking
[Applause]
this ball cued off the right off the end
of the bat to the right side and abraham
toro has reached base again
toro now with a four game hitting streak
is eight for 12 during that stretch
miles straw
well you want to get him out on this
pitch
chance for two there's one wilkerson on
to first they got him
straw can get down the line as quick as
almost anybody but the orioles turned
two in a hurry he even said as much too
that he
wanted to get the feel for that pitch
because it matches up great with that
fastball that has been very good so far
early in the start
jake gets great carry on that four-seam
fastball the 93 in the middle of the
zone still gets a lot of swings and
misses
on the ground backhanded by toro long
throw and
out at first base
abraham toro from deep third getting it
done defensively as well
as they get austin hayes by less than a
stride
so hoping to build on that as the astros
have jason castro leading off and castro
picks on the first pitch and ropes one
off the wall and right d.j stewart gets
the ball back in but not before castro
has a leadoff double to start the third
mccormick will bat here with two on and
nobody out
avoid it 2-2 pitch grounded towards the
whole past freddie galvez being waved
around is jason castro here comes the
throw by hayes not in time to second
goes mccormick he's safe astros lead one
to nothing astros with the bases loaded
still nobody out in the inning
driven center field mullins on the move
at the wall he will make the catch in
front of the wall tagging and trotting
home altuve moving to third mccormick
yuli did not miss a grand slam by a
whole lot but it's two-nothing astros on
the sac fly now you're not bats with a
runner on third in less than two outs
that ball hit well to left field all the
way back hayes he will watch this one go
jordan alvarez a three-run bomb
his fourth home run at camden yards and
four career games and the astros now
lead this game five to nothing
big man with the big shot
there it is again this time swung on by
wilkerson and
odarizi picks up his fifth strikeout
got him
odor rizzy with six strikeouts tonight
in the first 10 batters
went away in the fourth
[Music]
paul third strike
jayco to rizzy with seven strikeouts
through three and two thirds innings
swing and a miss fastball up odor rizzy
picks up strikeout number eight he's
only three off his career high and we're
in the fifth inning the one two to hayes
did he go around on the pitch away he
sure did says angel hernandez hayes down
on strikes nine k's for odor rizzy
on the ground first baseman julie guriel
is there one two three inning who needs
a first or a second pitch strike he
retires the side when falling behind all
three two and oh
first and third one out dylan tate the
new pitcher to face julie guriel
he hits one to left field should be deep
enough to score altuve making the play
is austin hayes his ninth sacrifice fly
on the season here's carlos correa
there's a ball sharply hit down the
right field line that's a fair ball
brantley will score jordan alvarez will
go first to third carlos correa the rbi
single astros now lead this game seven
to nothing
swing and a miss javier gets him
beaten with a fastball in the 3-2 pitch
that's two strikeouts for christian and
11 strikeouts for the astros
went out there in delta
line drive to center field mile straw is
there
picks it off the ground for the final
out of the seventh inning
one two three inning for javier who's
retired six in a row astros lead seven
to nothing as we head to the eighth
that ball hit to center field back goes
mullen still going back he's at the
track at the wall it's off the top of
the wall one run will score around third
comes the pinch runner garcia he'll
score
michael bradley a two rbi double the
astros in front nine to nothing
hits the ball hard past the diving first
baseman mancini around third comes
brantley he'll score
heading to third taylor jones on the rbi
double by garrett stubbs
astros now in double figures 10 to
nothing
[Applause]
so in steps michael franco
1-2 hit well
deep center field way back and there
goes the no hitter and the shout out
[Applause]
[Music]
swaying in a miss eight in a row for the
astros 10-2 victory tonight in baltimore